if I went to you five years ago and said
that in five years you would have a
series of events the biggest and worst
rights we we've seen in this country in
50 years far left extremists would tear
down the barricades of the White House
set fire to a guard post and the church
across the street the president would be
forced into a emergency bunker into an
emergency bunker underneath then uh
later on
several a hundred Trump supporters would
breach the capital during the accounting
of electoral college which would result
in federal agents raiding the homes of
people across the country even innocent
people having their homes raided by feds
and ultimately Donald Trump would not
only be indicted in multiple
jurisdictions but the Democrat doj would
be preparing indictments against his
lawyers and Democrats at the state level
would have indicted his lawyers
if I were to tell you all that you'd
tell me I was crazy I know for a fact
because when I said in 2018 that what we
are seeing on the ground will eventually
find its way to the federal government I
was I was told that I was crazy
Mike cernovich says that what we're
seeing right now is akin to the massacre
of Tsar Nicholas's family in the
Bolshevik Revolution but that happened I
believe that was a cause after the
actual Revolution or maybe a year or so
not getting my timelines right on this
one but they brought them locked them up
and then eventually said you know what
we can't risk your family surviving and
then massacred his family
call whatever you want you know we can
say that it's a civil war but I think
maybe that's unfair considering that
requires multiple factions actually in
some kind of opposition to each other
what may actually be happening is more
akin to the Bolshevik Revolution but
call it whatever you want Democrats and
various jurisdictions are using the
weight of government to attack their
political Rivals to the extent that they
have now in Georgia this news came out
it dropped around 1am or so
they have indicted lawyers for Donald
Trump in fact one of the lawyers for
Trump is actually at this point not a
big fan of trump and fairly pro-desantis
there's a lot to talk about with this
there are many Trump personalities
who started changing their tune a few
months after January 6 and then a year
or so after they're all of a sudden on
board the Santos calling Trump a grifter
and a con man
take a look at the statements they made
around or before January 6. when they
were saying there was fraud encouraging
people to be active encouraging people
to go down on January 6. I believe that
there are many personalities
lawyers Consultants social media
personalities who knew that because they
had advocated for what Trump was was was
trying to do with his legal team
because there are videos of them
advocating for action on January 6 they
would find themselves indebted at some
point
it's happening
they're going after Trump's lawyers The
Next Step likely going to be
personalities who are in contact with
Donald Trump's legal team who then took
to the airwaves be it social media
digital or television terrestrial and
advocated for his plans his policies and
for people to protest on January 6th
they'll say this was incitement and
furtherance of the conspiracy in Georgia
they're already saying that there are
many many more on indicted
co-conspirators in DC they're saying
that there are a few unindicted
co-conspirators and we expect they will
be indicted soon as well
I don't know where all this goes but
ladies and gentlemen escalation seems to
be the only place it can go and maybe
I'm wrong and I'd love to be wrong but
every time something happens that's
worse than it was a month ago I say it
seems like it'll get worse I don't know
what you call this period where
Democrats and multiple jurisdictions are
targeting the home of the former
president the former president and his
lawyers anyone who represented him
we already know what the j6ers many
lawyers dropped them as clients or
refused to take them on in the first
place
so let's talk about all of that and a
bit more before we get started head over
to castbrew.com because in these trying
times we're still selling products hey
if you want to support the show we sell
coffee we sponsor ourselves we make our
own coffee it's cast Brew Coffee we got
a great commercial starring Ian
Crossland look at his eyes they're
glowing because he loves that coffee you
can join the cast Brew Coffee Club
ground or mixed three bags per month
we've got a bunch of different blends we
got light dark medium and we have K-Cups
available so uh one way to support the
work we that we do and it seems rather
silly to be talking about it considering
the severity of what we're saying but uh
Hey buy our coffee also head over to
timcast.com click join us to become a
member and support us directly while you
still can
as a member you'll get access to our
uncensored members only shows we'll have
one of those up for you tonight at 10 pm
after we wrap up the public live portion
we jump over to the website and as
members you actually can submit
questions and talk to us and our guests
so do so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the URL
to this video if you like the work that
we do and you want to help out another
way word of mouth is the most powerful
way to help podcasts grow joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is conservative and what's up guys
thanks for having me super excited who
are you what do you do I'm a social
media
um political comedian I guess you will
uh Tick Tock Instagram
all the platforms
um I also Advocate uh for protecting
children in uh anti-grooming with gays
against groomers I've been part of that
for quite some time and also uh sex
trafficking in general
um trying to bring awareness to it
um so yeah we're many hats right on well
thanks for hanging out it should be fun
yeah thanks we got Phil how you doing I
am Phil Avanti lead singer of the heavy
metal band All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
anti-communist you got your work cut out
for you now I mean you know there's just
so many commies around nowadays you know
like well like 12 years ago or 10 years
ago something like that I wrote this
this op-ed complaining about Tom Morello
because he's a commie and everyone's
like oh no he's not are you sure blah
blah now if I wrote that and I was like
oh he's a commie everyone's like well
obviously and it's like people need to
like we need to go ahead again so you
think I'll go I'll go on and on and on
because I'm concerned with
anti-something because like I don't know
what you are but liberal Pro I'm liberal
I mean I mean I'm I'm I'm I believe in
the enlightenment philosophy I believe
that we can know reality I believe that
the truth does not change from person to
person people will see things
differently but what is true is true
um so it's part of what makes
instruments phenomenal in science is
that we don't have to rely on someone to
tell us what the result was we have an
instrument to decide or show us all I am
Ian Crossland and I am drinking the
pumpkin spice latte mix right it's light
it is delicious I put some peanut butter
powder and coconut water in and it
tastes like Reese's Pieces cups
let's get down and dirty dog oh earlier
today I did a Twitter space with Zach
Voorhees we talked about Ai and God it
was fascinating it's on my Twitter's
page but watch this show and I'll the
links on my page I'll tell you about it
later again hey Serge what's up uh I
will definitely check that out uh I'm
searching.com yeah yeah one final thing
okay I did an X space with the dude that
owns SpaceX
you think that was intentional when he
bought it when he renamed it you just
wanted to do it because it was that yeah
that owns SpaceX
Elon Musk yep the one and only he owns X
okay so the space right on yeah well
let's jump into this first story here we
go ladies and gentlemen from Reuters
Georgia charges Trump and former
advisers in 2020 election case hey hold
on there a minute Reuters those were
lawyers not advisors I guess you can
technically say that they were advisors
because they gave him legal advice as
lawyers but that's constitutionally
protected what does Michael Mouse call
this factual but not truthful yes it's
factual they advised him but they're
lawyers
former U.S president Donald Trump was
hit with a sweeping fourth set of
criminal charges on Monday when a
Georgia grand jury issued an indictment
accusing him of efforts to overturn his
2020 election laws to Democrat Joe Biden
to 98 indictment listing 19 defendants
and 41 criminal counts now
last night we talked about how
The Fulton County Court released the
indictment against Donald Trump
prematurely took it down called it a
fictitious document then denied it now
what they're saying it was it was a
sample document and it accidentally got
published it should never have happened
so uh they lied then or they're lying
now take your pick I think it's fairly
obvious they were planning to indict
Trump on uh bring these charges against
him well before a grand jury was
convened and more importantly
they could have done it years ago it is
being done today for political purposes
I want to show you the indictment and
some of the more silly elements of it
but the seriousness of it can be
explained right here on the front page
Fulton Superior Court
the state of Georgia versus Donald John
Trump Rudolph Giuliani who I believe was
his lawyer John Eastman also a lawyer
Mark Meadows that was uh Trump's who's
the chief of chief of staff that was
Mark Meadows
uh you've got uh who else do we have
Kenneth chaseborough I believe was a
lawyer Jeffrey Clark was a state
department attorney Jenna Ellis was also
an attorney interestingly Jenna Alice
has been rather anti-trump over the past
several months and has been somewhat CR
has been critical of him now but also
supporting DeSantis also people are
pulling up very old posts from her where
she was very anti-trump early on
Ray Smith Robert cheely Michael Roman
David Shafer David Shaffer that one's
actually fairly interesting because he
met with an alternate slate of electors
then told the press all that matters is
if the court cases proceed they'll have
an alternate slate of electors for that
he's being criminally charged Sean still
Stephen Lee Harrison Floyd
trevian uh trevian cootie this is funny
because that's uh Kanye West's publicist
apparently she had advocated on behalf
of the Trump campaign to an election
official that they should pursue an
investigation into voting machines
that's a criminal conspiracy
Sydney Powell yep Kathleen Latham who I
believe was one of the election
officials who opened the door for the
Trump campaign in Coffee County Scott
Hall and Misty Hampton another election
official I believe opened the door
so what you have here
you have a state department attorney
being criminally charged you have a
series of lawyers being criminally
charged Mark Meadows was the chief of
staff of Donald he was you checked yeah
okay that's what I thought I thought I
thought I was right wanted to be sure
though
criminally charged in Georgia why
because of a legal Theory pertaining to
what the vice president is or isn't
allowed to do here's my view
Mike Pence does have the authority to
reject votes in the electoral vote count
Richard Nixon had done it before he
chose Democrat votes over Republican
votes despite the fact that Democrats
were certified as in 1960. so using that
legal Theory and precedent Mike Pence
would have been able to do it well Mike
Pence didn't do it there you go whatever
you don't kind of like the guy a lot of
people don't like the guy but that's it
they had they had a legal Theory and
plan they asked Mike Pence he said no
it's over now we can see exactly why
Mike Pence refused to engage I'm willing
to bet they went him and said if you go
along with this you will be arrested you
will be charged and we will destroy
everything about your life the
interesting thing is they kept making
the argument the vice president had no
authority to do this and then Mike Pence
made the mistake of doing a TV uh
interview recently where he said I could
have pushed the votes back and it would
have gone to the state uh to to the
house delegations the house House of
Representatives so he knew exactly what
his authority and Powers were there were
numerous articles written by left-wing
personalities journalists where they
explained if Mike Pence rejected
electoral votes then house delegations
would vote for the president that's the
normal procedure so Mike Pence Democrats
the media everybody began lying saying
he never had the authority to do so in
the big in the first place which wasn't
true they then changed the laws later on
to say yeah he can't do that but at the
time he could so what we were really
looking at was nothing criminal but
legal Theory
the next people in my view who will face
criminal indictments
television media political high-level
influential personalities who are in
communication with Donald Trump or his
lawyers who then went on Twitter Youtube
Fox News whatever and advocated for
these election strategies advocated for
legal challenges and to find uh votes
advocated for the Dominion claims and
additionally those who encouraged
protest on January 6th and those who
cheered on January 6th there are a lot
of people I'm not going to name them let
this be their own business
that pre-january 6 were cheering saying
yes yes people should go down and saying
that people should engage in certain
behaviors
then January 6 happened
some people actually cheered on what
happened that day on social media saying
why are people mad about this you've had
leftists the gravel Institute cheered
for January 6 not that they advocated
for it
months go by a year goes by and you may
notice that some of these personalities
became hardcore to Santa supporters and
absolutely anti-trump
I think there's a very obvious reason
why they were crying and shaking and
begging in in hopes that if they turn on
Trump the doj the state level uh
prosecutors will Overlook them and not
criminally charge them now I can't say
who uh uh necessarily holds those I
think it's I think many of the people
who turned on Trump probably felt that
way
I'm not gonna say I can tell you
definitively any of these individuals I
will however point out Jenna Ellis who
turned on Trump recently has been
advocating heavily for Ron DeSantis and
is now facing criminal charges and is
trying to raise money the sad thing here
is that Ardent Trump supporters are not
the biggest fans of Jenna Ellis now and
so she has no support she's raised a few
thousand dollars for her legal defense I
think she deserves a legal defense but
by turning on Trump and trying to go
into the Santa's Camp you're looking at
mustering up what 10 of the GOP yeah but
does it matter at this point like if you
supported that from the beginning and
then you like last minute ditch effort
like oh I'm gonna support DeSantis in
hopes that I'm not gonna get in trouble
I mean obviously it doesn't matter right
it's an ancient struggle session tactic
to get someone to denounce their own
views publicly before you serve theirs
before we take them to sentence Socrates
refused to do it he spoke the truth
until the moment he died
um some people you know it is an old it
is an old battle tactic an authoritarian
tactic to get the crowd because then you
can say well they admitted it so
right she you know she whatever they're
charging them under Rico what does that
mean criminal Enterprise saying that as
a criminal organization that was
conspiring to engage in illegal
behaviors I think it's that is
ridiculous and I mean the whole thing in
my opinion is ridiculous I don't think
anybody that's charged Donald Trump is a
republican at all right the entire thing
is Democrats right uh well no they
didn't they say Jackson is Jack Smith a
Democrat they they look you had a
republican go on TV in in uh in Georgia
and be like Trump ruined the Republican
party yeah you've got Neo party you've
got tokens neocon and uniparty shells I
want to read for you act 22 of the
indictment
they say on or about the third day of
December 2020 Donald John Trump caused
to be tweeted from the Twitter account
at realdonaldtrump quote Georgia
hearings now on oannn Amazing this was
an overt act in furtherance of the
conspiracy
now a lot of people have said there are
a lot of Provisions in here about
tweeting and one it was insulting Mike
Pence calling him a wimp or something
like that and that uh these were illegal
activities no no these aren't illegal
actions they are arguing that Trump
tweeting proves he was engaged in a
conspiracy that he was advancing his
conspiracy by tweeting this that's so
ridiculous to eat to attempt to to to to
to to defend yourself or or use the
means that you're the legal means at
your disposal to try to affect an
outcome like it's the point was that
these means were legal to try to say hey
let's recount you know to see if there
was some kind of uh some kind of fraud
that's perfectly legal the fact that
they're trying to prosecute I think I
honestly think the fact that they're
trying to prosecute people that were in
any way in business with Trump or or on
team Trump is this essentially boils
down to and this might seem a little
hyperbolic but essentially goes down to
the same reason that they just smoked
the dude in uh in Utah I think that the
the 75 year old dude that was making
threats about the president they could
have wrapped him up the guy could barely
walk they could have kicked in his door
and got him without killing him they
didn't have to drag his body out and
leave him laying on the sidewalk you
know like they didn't have to do that
there was an intent there which is to
intimidate the American people or
intimidate people that are
anti-establishment and the same thing is
going on I think for the people that
have worked with with Donald Trump
they're trying to intimidate people that
are anti-establishment saying look if
you would help people that are against
the establishment against whatever you
want to call it whether you want to call
the Deep state or you want to call it
the bureaucracy I don't give a crap what
name you put on it but if you're against
that then we're going to unleash as much
uh you know effort or as much of
attention as it requires to neutralize
you and it's the biggest most powerful
government in history it can do multiple
things at once taking care of you your
your issues is that they can do that and
still do all the all the all the same
stuff that they they have planned so
it's not it's not some kind of problem
for them to shut down shut people up or
to shut people down or or to intimidate
people into silence do you think there
are any personalities who got visits
from Democrats law enforcement and we're
told you're gonna come out against
Donald Trump or we're gonna come after
you I'm sure I and probably the bigger
personalities right I don't think yeah
the big personality is so but then it it
you know it trickles down a little bit
too because then you have the small
small time right like
someone like me who's on Instagram or
any of us that are on other social media
platforms that by the way the Biden
Administration is using young gen Z
influencers to his Advantage where we
don't or where the conservatives don't
but could they go after us too then
could they go up to the little guy's
show they do it all the time by Banning
your accounts that's what they're doing
I think that I think I honestly do think
this is all about intimidation I think
that the reason that like I said that
the dude in Utah got smoked I think the
reason they're going after all of the
the people that that were Associates of
trump and stuff like that I think that
it's something that that the
establishment wants look they've said
clearly after January 6 there were
members former members of the
intelligence uh apparatus uh I forget
the guy's name I think it was Brandon
was the guy that was on but he was
talking he's like anyone that has
anti-government uh opinions or your you
know feelings everyone in America that
is right of Center to some degree is
anti-American or anti-government right
they want smaller government even people
that are like establishment
right-leaning people there's ostensibly
smaller government but like anyone
that's like a Maga person or a
Libertarian or any kind of anarchist or
or Independents that want to limit the
uh the military-industrial complex or
people that want to limit limit the uh
the security State and the the the
surveillance apparatus all of those
people are the enemy of the government
now but the problem is I want a healthy
government and if that means it needs to
slim down because the government has
become obese I'm okay with the
government going on a workout program
that's the problem I don't I don't agree
if the government wants to preserve
itself it needs to take itself seriously
and restructure itself
that's why we need to restructure from
time to time yeah as a unit how do we do
that well Vivek ramaswamy suggests that
we cut the FBI I think it's the FBI and
then send a lot of the you know fire a
lot of the administer Traders
administrative guys you know but then
move a lot of the necessary pieces to
other parts of government Homeland
Security CIA
um Department of energy he has it listed
in fact and I retweeted it it's on
Twitter I'm on I'm on the same page with
you homie Vivek is great like I I think
that he's a great candidate and I think
nobody ever say his name the cake man we
gotta call him the cake man because it's
the vague like cake you gotta call him
the cake man so that'll stick but to get
people to remember anybody that runs or
anybody that has an opposing opinion
from it this is my opinion from this
current Administration or the left is
automatically just they're like no no no
no because they've now thrown out all
these racist homophobic xenophobic like
all these words if you're for some
reason anti-government we're seeing it
now that people are thinking that the
American flag makes you racist and like
it's just it's a never-ending Pro no
matter who you are if you come out
against the current Administration
you're wrong whether it's 5x
sorry about that Vivek she forgives you
yes thank you uh or anybody else you
know I mean they're even doing it to
Kennedy and he's one of them it's I
think it's important to remember that
anti-government and smaller government
is not the same thing you need a healthy
government sometimes it needs to be
smaller or larger to make it healthy but
if you love your government you want it
to be the healthiest it can be and that
means sometimes slimming down the blow
oh I don't swear love the government
what's the love about the government
yeah not really it's a chance for us to
you know coordinate National Defense and
protect each other it's military and
economic Transportation I don't like I
don't want I mean well I mean obviously
I'm I'm as a Libertarian kind of leaning
kind of guy I want the small the smaller
government so as much cutting as as you
can do I'm going to be down with so yeah
let me start oh yeah I want to show you
a few examples samples uh so we did get
a Super Chat uh virtual rifle says read
act 156 there's a handful of uh of Acts
in this in further into the conspiracy
one of them is a good example act 156
Donald John Trump committed the felony
fence of a solicitation of violation of
Oath by public officer when he said to
Brad raffensberger a public officer
quote decertif uh he uh I'm sorry he
said uh I want to make sure that I'll
just read it uh public officer he asked
him to engage in conduct constituting
the felony offense of violation of Oath
by public officer by unlawfully quote
decertifying the election or whatever
the correct legal remedy is and announce
the true winner in willful and
intentional violation of the terms of
the oath of said person as prescribed by
law
that's probably the perfect example of
what this is Donald Trump said to the
Secretary of State
engage in the correct legal remedy for
what is going on and that is a is a
violation of your oath of office or
solicitation of violation of us to ask
someone to enact correct legal remedies
in fact he said do a thing which may or
may not have been legal or the correct
legal remedy meaning if the thing was
illegal you instead do the collect
correct legal remedy so how is asking
someone to do a legal remedy
illegal because they are just indicting
it's it's
indictments don't matter as we've
pointed out time and time again women
aren't legally allowed to skydive in
Florida on Sunday ain't no woman's
getting arrested for that right
disorderly conduct what does that mean
yeah exactly I've seen people in the
moment engaged in free speech be
criminally charged with disorderly
conduct
that's a charge they can slap on anyone
for any reason at any time
and then they can arrest you remove you
and then maybe you go to court and you
say your honor I was just speaking and
the judge says okay you're free to go
but you still got locked up
if you don't get bail you could be in
there for a month or longer if you get
locked up on the weekend on a Friday
you're there over the weekend
that sounds what you just read about
that of him asking a guy to do the legal
remedy and then they're saying that what
he did was illegal by asking that guy to
do a legal thing I don't I still don't
understand that and maybe that's because
there's something in there that was
here's another word here's another good
one Byron York says
it has to lead to an illegal act
eventually doesn't it look at David
Shafer g-a-g-o-p chair he meets with
Trump quote electors December 14 2020
explains to the press that electors are
contingent on Trump winning a lawsuit
and that is forgery false statement and
impersonating a public officer that's
what they're charging him with
alternate electors have been done before
this is the Democrats just basically
saying we will do whatever we want and
we will crush you and right now what are
we getting from Republicans in the GOP
angry tweets
fit
angry tweets it's
I'm looking forward to getting a monitor
in here because I gotta I gotta read
this yeah so and they want this to go
all the way up you know they want to
prolong this for as long as possible
because ultimately they don't want Trump
to the Republicans well maybe both they
want to preserve order that's for sure
so the Democrats want definitely want
Trump and I mean I don't know
I mean I don't have a whole lot of of
faith in in Trump's ability to to win
like if he's the nominee I'll vote for
him I'm gonna vote for whoever's not the
Democrat not Biden um but like I don't
you know I don't I don't see that that
that he's gonna make a whole lot of uh
especially with all the indictments I
don't see that you don't think there's a
lot of people over you don't think that
this motivates people more to want to
vote for not not people that don't not
people that don't already kind of like
him if you're not somewhat uh
sympathetic to Trump already if you
weren't I don't think this is making
people sympathetic to him now I don't
think it's sympathetic to Trump pers I
think it's more of a
at this point it's like okay because
he's being indicted all these times I
I'm I'm gonna vote for I don't know I I
feel like it's a mind thing I don't
think that you're wrong I think there
are people that do feel that way I don't
know that it's enough to be to win the
presidency yeah okay my opinion I mean
there is no right and wrong I guess
answer but well I mean we don't know you
can't know until after until the
election yeah but I I personally don't
feel like I feel like there are people
that strongly want Trump
um and there are people that are always
going to be committed to Trump I just
don't know that they're I don't know
that there are enough people that would
go over to Trump uh that have been in
the middle I just don't know I don't
know who that Vote or the United voter
that goes over is I don't know I've I've
uh it's really funny there are a lot of
people who are terminally online
and uh
these activists online say things like
touch grass and it's like bro you are a
leftist on Twitter who does nothing but
just we like I'm I'm going we we go out
on the weekends to various different
middle of nowhere places often and you
know we talk to people who ask them
questions and I found something really
interesting between With Friends of
Friends uh extended family members and
just people out in the General Public
people that I know a couple years ago
who are passively anti-trump have become
passively anti-democrat doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to vote
for Trump but a few years ago you know
we're coming on the back end of the of
the coveted lockdowns and the pandemic
and all that they were very much on
board with the corporate narrative
then you kind of destroyed the economy
destroy their trust force them do things
they didn't want to do lock them in a
box and now I'm talking to some of these
people and they're saying things that
are passively anti-establishment
anti-democrat so I don't know where they
end up voting but if Donald Trump
becomes the once again the Avatar of the
anger and frustration of these people he
gets their vote
someone someone tweeted a good point
that people aren't necessarily voting
for Trump they're voting for what the
machine hates the most and fears that's
it yeah I watched Trump he did a speech
today I think on Truth social four
minutes he talked about basically about
Joe Biden and he could call it the Biden
crime family talking about 20 million
that they got from Jesus was it China or
Ukraine where's bidens are getting their
money from Orange States and like that's
what people are voting against I think
when you're talking about voting against
the narrative it's voting against a
president who had a son our president's
son was on the board of a in a random
country on Earth some Ukraine halfway
across earth the president's son was on
an energy board in some crazy foreign
country and the guy was a crackhead what
in the and now it's at war with Russia
like what in the hell put these pieces
together uh and that's what people are
voting against if they start if they
vote against them I want to jump to the
story from Yahoo Huffington Post Jenna
Ellis mocked for invoking God after
getting indicted well you know let her
invoke whatever she wants to invoke she
tweeted the Democrats and the Fulton
County DEA are criminalizing the
practice of law I am resolved to trust
the Lord and I will simply continue to
honor praise and serve him I am deeply
appreciative of all my friends who have
reached out offering encouragement and
support Jenna Ellis was a lawyer for
Trump now she's getting roasted by
Trump's most Ardent supporters we've got
this tweet from Laura Loomer
professional liar and Trump
backstabberger John Alice was indebted
last night for the last several months
she has been attacking Donald Trump
online with Team DeSantis she betrayed
Donald Trump I personally think she
intentionally sabotaged him because I
can't fathom anyone can be as stupid as
she is and decided to support Rhonda
Sanders instead she's been attacking
Trump online for having his pack pay his
legal fees even though his supporters
are more than happy to donate to the
cause Jenna has called Trump supporters
grifters and she's been retweeting other
Descent of supporters who attacked
Donald Trump now she is crying online
begging Trump supporters to donate to
her legal defense fund Laura goes on and
calls her vile and a liar
but I do think it's it's really
interesting
I'm not going to say I can speak for
Jenna Ellis
personally specifically I have no idea
but there are many people
who hey go look at their uh their
YouTube videos go look at things they
said when they were guests on TV shows
who advocated for action on January 6
who advocated for Donald Trump's legal
actions who advocated for alternate
slates of electors and all of these
things directly demanding it be done
saying that people should occupy or
people should do this that are otherwise
how long do you think until Democrats in
various jurisdictions start going after
them saying that they were inciting and
encouraging and those that were in
communication with Donald Trump were
acting in furtherance of the conspiracy
I don't well my thought is
it's tough to tell but that what they
want is Donald Trump to not be president
and for there to be order across the
United States so if they start
persecuting the population I think that
will serve as a breakdown of order I I
don't know how far you know like when
you get what you want you don't want to
take any more than that you got enough
that's you're saying that they fear they
could go too far yes
I'm not I'm not so sure I don't care how
far they go we have not seen an instance
of de-escalation yeah like I was just
gonna say like where's the off ramp what
what's the offering what is the the
thing that makes someone say we don't
escalate to the next obvious level
federal law enforcement rated the home
of some woman in Alaska because she
looked like another man who went looked
like another woman who went into the
capital if they are willing to lock
there's a man locked up right now it's
been two two and a half years without
charge or trial
because he won't disavow Donald Trump
he's in DC in in prison if they're
willing to do that to random people
are you saying that they would just
decide like well this guy's got a
million followers on on you know Twitter
or whatever and he was telling people to
go there and engage in this Behavior you
think they're going to ignore Alex Jones
well if random Alex Jones was leading
one of the rallies outside the Capitol
building but he said don't go in but
they're not they don't care right well
they they they're not doing it to random
necessarily random people the guy was at
Jan six that's why his and the woman
they thought she was a chance it'll be
the people with the wrong person no but
they have to be random
they have done random I I I I I believe
I don't know they have knock on it it's
not random it's always politically
motivated there's always people with the
wrong political opinion so it's not
random no right so if you have the right
I think he's saying people who are into
January 6th correct yeah I have heard
that they have gone to people's homes
that weren't even at Gen 6 and that's to
your point what if I did a podcast two
years ago and I said yeah I really don't
care what happened on January 6th like
sure it was fine they can just come to
you and come knock on your door and say
Hey you because you agreed with what
happened on j6 we're we're taking you in
well I think more likely they're going
to go to the individuals that
pre-january 6 who are telling people to
go there
and uh there are a lot of quotes that I
won't say but there were people who were
advocating for direct action at the
Capitol on these like now these people
were never there right but they're going
to say that they were inciting
insurrection
more importantly there are high profile
personalities who are in direct
communication with Trump and his legal
team and then went on TV or YouTube or
whatever and said either as guests or
hosts this is the plan this is what
they're doing it's totally legal and
everyone should support them for it
they're gonna say that person was part
of the conspiracy
Trump trump told them we need to build
support use your platform to encourage
everyone to help us and they're going to
say there might be people that wanted a
march on the Capitol and a Siege of the
capital and then a prevention of the
legal process there might be people that
did that but a lot of those people were
just there and that emergent phenomenon
of mob mentality took over a lot of
people were waved in by cops I've heard
cops are taking selfies with people yeah
it wasn't like everyone went there to
overthrow the government that's not what
happened a lot of people got wrapped up
in this and I don't even know if Donald
Trump wanted to overthrow the government
I don't know this is the point right now
if they're willing to go after some 60
year old dude who walked around outside
and didn't even go in the building there
are people who are criminally charged
who never entered the building but they
were on the grounds and that's that's
good enough if they're gonna go after
them yeah they went to the extent where
they went to a woman's house in Alaska
and she wasn't even in the building and
raided her home she she was actually in
Washington though she was in Washington
at like Trump's at the Trump speech or
whatever but she never went in the
Capitol building she looked like someone
she's like a similar coat so they rated
her house well there's people that were
saying that there were hot dog vendors
there like there were people that were
playing music they went for people that
were on the outskirts of all of this
that was going on like
if you were in a picture oh yeah we know
that we we see that person we're gonna
go ahead and you're arrested we're
closing your bank account down we're
doing this doing that blocking you up
whatever whatever they did to them I
have no idea I wasn't there but I will
say this as an influencer online
was I asked by followers hey are you
going to go I didn't think it was going
to go that way I thought it was going to
go like a totally different way where
like we were going to get hurt because
people didn't like Trump supporters so I
was like I'm good on this one I would
recommend you guys don't go right
because maybe we'll get hurt but they
could go after all the little guys like
myself at the time that might have been
like go there let's go there let's let's
it's just crazy I think it's going to be
bigger personalities because as we move
into 2024 their goal is to silence
anyone who would provide public support
for Trump yeah so first they go for his
legal team anybody who helped him many
of the j6ers can't get lawyers
right then they're going to Target
moderate to large personalities who are
in the Trump periphery who are
advocating for and supporting Trump's
presidency because they want to hurt
that they want people to fear supporting
Trump fear and there are a lot of people
who used to be the most Ardent Trump
supporters who turned on a dime and are
now saying Trump's a grifter and a con
man into Santa says the light in the way
and I just think that's very very funny
because I think I've I've these people
posted YouTube videos
you know where they were very very on
board with Trump and now all of a sudden
they're panicking right I think I think
they started to get scared interesting
you know I've I've heard I've there's
background there's background talk and I
try to avoid saying stuff like this but
I'm sure most of you who are listening
I've heard something this to this effect
that people believe Ron DeSantis is a
deep state plant
and it's a little bit of an exaggeration
Donald Trump supported Ronda Sanders so
whatever but there are people who
believe that DeSantis is supported by
Deep State Elements by these these you
know uniparty fundraisers
so that he can be the safe landing for
Trump supporters and off ramp for them
they want Total Control the uni party
will take control Donald Trump is an
anomalous how do you get people to stop
supporting Trump and support someone
who's your controlled opposition
Rhonda santis does all the culture wore
stuff right floor looks really good but
then when Trump comes back Ron can't
manage the campaign and then he fumbles
but there are a lot of people and who
who believe that and again I'm not
saying that's true I'm saying that when
you like backdoor private conversations
with people involved in politics their
attitude is you see the people who begin
funding Ron DeSantis and it looks like
they're hoping he can be more
controllable than Trump and Trump
supporters will back him well the only
way you're going to get a trump
supporter to not support Trump is do all
this other stuff that we're talking
about to him when you because then you
won't have a choice if he's not on the
ticket right so then you're gonna go
then by default then you would go for
someone like the Santa's Trump isn't
going to lose his current supporters he
never will nothing he can
sorry but he can skin a cat online and
people will have excuses for why he did
that and they're still going to vote for
him his base is strong in my opinion
there are no and the only way you're
gonna get though sorry but the only way
you're gonna get I mean I love him like
I love what he did for the country so
for me I never wavered from that I'm a
Floridian so I think Rhonda Santos needs
to fix what hurricane Ian did to us last
year before he starts running around the
country doing all this presidential
stuff but you have to get rid of trump
somehow in order for his supporters to
not have him to vote for there are
instances of people that are like well
vivek's younger smarter faster and he
wants to continue what some of the
policies Trump was doing I'm going with
the younger smarter candidate there are
some people I think you're right for the
most part yeah people that are
emotionally invested in a human tend to
stay emotionally invested in the human I
personally serve a function I serve the
function of President and I don't care
what person it is at the moment I want
the best candidate right
policy policy personal temperament
policy things like that temperament's a
big part of it yeah the big part of
where Trump's misgivings is that people
don't like him that he's alienated and
insulted so many people that behind the
scenes are like yo get rid of that guy
he's an like we don't want that
same thing what happened to soccer I'm
not going to bring up Socrates all night
but that's the same thing Socrates
brilliant man poor social skills pissed
off too many people in high up positions
so that's a problem with temperament and
you need to be a grand unifier
presidential you know I want to read
this from Mike cernovich
we have an initial tweet from J Michael
Waller who said not even the Soviet
Communist party did this type of legal
weaponization during its last years in
power
Mike cernovich says right we are in the
early stages where Bolsheviks are
Shoring up power the Cold War analogies
don't hold up we are in the quote the
tsar and his family are massacred phase
of History
I'm curious what you guys think
because obviously uh you know I was I I
probably still trending on Twitter I was
trending all day for saying for like the
800th time you were in a civil war but
this one time people were shocked that I
said it oh come on it's a meme
but I I I don't know if Civil War is a
fair way to assess it because we may not
be inactive War as some people describe
it but I think at the fundamental
definition of multiple factions fighting
over control of government you are
certainly in something akin to that and
many people say well maybe it's a cold
Civil War and that's a fair point as
well or it could just be a Bolshevik
communist or Communist Revolution I've
said a bunch of times I think that we're
in the middle of a uh a cultural
evolution in the United States similar
to the one that happened in China so
it's a Communist Revolution a cultural
revolution yeah I know but communist
yeah communities are involved that's for
sure yeah the thing is that it's not
communist like you know back in the day
like the philosophies have evolved so
this is a a you come want to call it
neo-communist or something like that
neon Marxist that's fine because it's a
new version it's based you know there's
oh there's there it's like there's
multiple different kind of it's almost
like it's a religion one overarching
religion and there's different sects of
it you know what I mean
um so I'm not like I know I've seen on
Twitter there are people that are upset
that you said that and stuff but it's
like like I I've kind of felt like we're
in the in the middle of a a not a an
actual Civil War obviously because
there's not you know
um considerable violence in the street
between warring factions but we are in
an information War isn't there no
there's not like
there's not okay because I'm talking
about like actual gun fights right oh
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
and that's and that's what they're
that's what they're the people that are
upset they're upset because Civil War
brings to mind gun fights in American
streets and that's what they don't want
people to be referring to and so I want
to be completely clear we are not in a
civil war because we're not in there's
not gunfights over territory with
factions fighting the United States
government are fighting each other
there's an information war going on I
agree with that Civil War cold civil war
Civil War period yes that I agree with
but it's not we're not gun fights we've
already had uh people killed yes we've
uh we've had numerous there's political
violence there's there's occupations
autonomous zones yep uh weaponization of
government one faction yeah one faction
arresting their political opponents all
of this that's why I said earlier today
all the stuff that's happening here
people that are outside of the United
States context outside of the western
context when they look at us and they
see oh one political party is
persecuting their opponents they're
arresting people they're charging as
lawyers blah blah they see that and
they're like that is all Banana Republic
and no matter how much Bill Crystal
and the morons the New York Times want
to shove their head in the sand and
swear up and down that America is
different the rest of the world sees
right through their horseshit right
through it because only
unreliable and furthermore again the the
fact that this makes America look
unreliable only hurts the dollar when
it's never been weaker when we've never
had more debt when we've never had a a
well it's been a long time since we've
had this the type of uh income
inequality that we do have in in the US
there are a lot of problems that all of
this stuff only makes worse you know so
I I don't see Stephen Marsh says that we
are in civil Strife which is the period
that occurs right before a civil war
happens civil civil Strife civil Strife
is when you have I think what do you say
like 70 or more per year political
deaths and the US is well beyond that
most people just don't track these
things but what people also don't
realize and I have to say this every
single time
there was a revolution in Egypt two of
them actually within like a span of a
year of each other if if you went to the
mall you wouldn't know anything was
going on and because of this people
watch movies
and they think Civil War means you look
out your window and guys in uniforms are
marching down the street yeah go watch
different go watch the videos of the
Syrian Civil War where you see people
walking around with groceries and going
grocery shopping like people don't stop
surviving and living and doing basic
things like eating food and going to the
grocery store simply because somewhere
there's fighting going on when I worked
for vice we wanted to do this
documentary on Syria this is the like
the peak of the Civil War because in
Damascus they were advertising tourism
in the United States we were getting ads
for Damascus nightlife and we thought
that would be absolutely wild to go to
Damascus and document how people were
just living their lives while there's
like sarin gas attacks happening 50
miles away highways being taken over
people were blowing each other up with
shells and their snipers everywhere but
in the city
you wouldn't have known for the most
part so because of because of I I think
condensed history and movies
people assume that there can't be any
kind of warfare because the average
person is going grocery shopping and I'm
like yeah that's that that's what I
witnessed and every place I've been to
so does the southern border or any of
the crime in any major city any of that
other stuff contribute to the currency
100 so that's what I was saying so let's
say this because there is I mean the
death that the gun violence in in
Chicago and LA and New York is kind of
Civil War the southern border I think is
the biggest the biggest component that
people should consider when it comes to
the escalation in the Civil War
let's say that by hard definitions we
are in civil Strife as Stephen Marsh
described it in his book titled the next
civil war he's actually a he described
himself as a multicultural democracy
kind of guy and More in favor of the
liberal world view so be it and he says
we're not quite in Civil War yet civil
Strife let's say that's the case
there's a various scenarios that could
occur which will lead us into full-scale
Civil War and it's not going to be this
ridiculous Clan banging a gavel on a
Podium it's nonsense what it's going to
be is that groups of militia will start
forming on the southern border because
of the crisis you've got an old man
traffickers were crossing his property
they get shot and killed I don't know if
he's the one who did it they arrest him
the guy his own land his own own
property traffickers coming across his
property he defends his property they
arrest him he's gonna go to prison
eventually you're going to have people
say the federal government has abandoned
us there's no law enforcement down here
and the drug and human traffickers are
running rampant
we've already had what do they call
themselves The Minute Men in the past
and various militia groups at what point
do they actually then just assert
territory and all of a sudden
this could already be happening right
now by the way because these stories
have been uh persistent for the past 10
years or so
right now there could be a faction of
people on a certain point of the
Southern border say Arizona Arizona is
probably a good state for it that
there's open board uh barrier-less
border and they don't recognize Federal
Authority because the federal
government's abandoned them like I'll
put it this way they're not actively
planting flags and saying there's no
government they're saying that doesn't
pertain to us I have I don't care they
then start acting on their on their own
behalf what happens when one of these
groups
sees someone smuggling children
traffickers which happens a lot all the
time and they stop these traffickers a
gunfight breaks out and they kill these
guys and then the federal government
tries to arrest them
the thing about Civil War is that it's
not going to be people people have this
view of Civil War because of the
American Civil War that it'll be two
factions who will all sign treaties
together in various States will be alike
we're all working together in shake
hands when in reality it's going to be
various factions within States and if
you take a look at how Syria devolved
into Civil War it was various factions
fighting the government and they all had
different perspectives and Views and
eventually started coming together and I
think that was the free Syrian Army I
could be wrong
we could see something similar where you
have pockets you have groups that feel
the federal government is is derelict or
is is uh illegitimate the indictments
against Donald Trump at the federal
level if Trump is removed from the
ballot how soon until sentiment grows in
various rural areas where they're like
we don't answer to you anymore you are
not the government it takes only 10 guys
or so to assert that ideology that world
view that if Donald Trump is removed
from the ballot then whoever's in office
is not the actual government confidence
shatters one of the things I think
they're trying to do with the
indictments is to maintain confidence
that their power is absolute but that
does not work it never works that just
leads to Rapid destabilization the
Soviet Union only that's at 69 years
perhaps we get a Bolshevik style
revolution in the United States
Democrats in their crackpot neo-marxists
gain power and it lasts 30 years who
knows or or maybe when that does happen
you will get various roaming factions of
individuals in rural areas that don't
answer to the federal government anymore
and the federal government can't contain
them and starts to ignore them people
need to understand the amount of
Personnel in the federal government is
not large enough to contain widespread
unrest not at the urban level but at the
rural level where people are just simply
saying we don't answer to you or they
put up checkpoints or they just outright
stop paying taxes or something like that
I mean didn't didn't they set up like
what was it Chas a thing remember when
they set up that whole yeah how many
days the autonomous I mean how many days
is that George Floyd autonomous that I
think was like a year or two
so why can't why wouldn't that that's
exactly what I'm talking about yeah
exactly I mean you can kind of strike in
a city
I wouldn't put it past them yeah right
imagine what would happen and this is
this is a point James Lindsay makes that
the reaction is the goal that either
they're trying to force you to allow
perverts to groom your children or they
get you to react and claim your hateful
bigots and they use it as justification
that part imagine the inverse imagine a
group of right-wing conservative types
who are peacefully occupying land that
is controlled by the federal government
the Bundys for instance remember all
that that he's actually scheduled to go
back to jail I think on Thursday so back
to jail I just I I don't let me confirm
that but I read that yeah but and I
don't wanna I don't want to conflate
necessarily that was a different
circumstance but imagine there's swaths
of federal land that are completely you
know unused but it's federal land and a
group of guys are just like we're gonna
start utilizing this we don't recognize
the authority of the government what's
the government going to do imagine they
show up and drone strike as Ian suggests
yeah that reaction will result in more
people and their confidence shattered in
government amen Bundy was a arrested
three days ago for what uh defamation
what and he was released yesterday
defamation that's civil tort that's not
criminal arrest warrants since mid-april
after an Ada County Idaho judge found
him in contempt of court confusing to
show up to legal proceedings interesting
for nearly a year so that he just got
let out yesterday can't move property
or large cash sums for two weeks
eventually you're just going to have a
community I mean you look at uh rich men
north of Richmond the viral power of the
song 10 million views in a couple days
wow confidence shattered in government
is what leads to Civil War not a group
of people who are organized and then
sign a document and say we hereby
declare it's when random people just say
you're illegitimate get off my property
I'll put it this way if a guy showed up
to your house let's say you got it let's
say you got an acre in a suburban area
or rural area and one day a guy being
carried in one what are those things
called where it's got the sticks and the
guys carry it and the guy sits in the
middle I don't know yeah let's say
they're like a throne yeah it's not a
throne it's called something else I
don't know a word they're carrying him
Egyptians he says puts me down puts me
down they put him down he walks onto
your property and says you will now
tithe you will you will uh pay me 20 for
I am your king
what
all right what are you talking what are
you talking about no you're not right
what if a guy walked onto your property
flashed a badge and said that he was the
uh the the the Neo Lord declared of the
uh of the current
you know region or whatever you'd be
like wait what like what's this badge
that would be a little bit confusing
most people don't know what a
comptroller is so if someone shows up
with a badge and says they're in charge
a lot of people right now are just like
okay we still do have the United States
people being like look I don't know you
are showing me a warrant but a lot of
people just submit
the point comes when there will be a
legitimate law enforcement officer from
an agency no one's heard of or doesn't
care about or even from let's say like
the FBI and people just don't respect
them because they feel when the FBI goes
after Donald Trump in this way and they
see on news that it appears to be
completely political and illegitimate
they say these people aren't actually
enforcing the law anymore why would I
the only only reason why you'd agree to
do anything they say is out of fear of
death
well there's a lot of people that don't
and that's and that's terrifying they
don't fear death so what happens when
they say uh morbidly OB 70 year old guy
who's posting online that he's going to
take action against the government very
serious ways that people should not do
then they show up to his house what does
he do the latest report on that guy at a
Provo Utah was that he had a loaded 357
Magnum pointed at the federal officers
that's the kind of stuff that I'm
talking about now I want to make sure
I'm clear on this there is a path to
victory that
is through the legal system is by
electing Donald Trump
they can't they're not guaranteed
Victory this is why they're indicting as
lawyers
they want a reaction they want people to
get violent they are desperate for it
because people are shifting towards
Trump trump is winning in the polls in
many states like I said over the past
year or so people went from being
passively anti-trump to passively
anti-democrat uh anti-establishment I'm
not saying they're voting for Trump I'm
saying that they're losing confidence
and they are desperate to maintain it
one of the only ways they get it is if
Trump supporters go nuts so they're
hoping that by going after Trump they
get that you said interesting thing into
that they're not anti-democrat they're
anti-establishment and the establishment
used to be Republican in 2006. it was
George Bush's establishment uh war
mongering party for whatever reason
these business bureaucrats behind the
scenes now snagged onto the Democratic
party super delegates make it nice
because they can just pick their
candidate no matter who gets voted what
and people are tired of it we need we're
having a global Revolution right now of
artificial intelligence of conscious
just the way people think since The
Internet's been developed the way people
interface with each other and and we
need a government to catch up to that
Mike cernovich made a really important
point he said did you know that the
Republicans currently have a comparable
majority to what Nancy Pelosi had when
she was targeting Trump with all of
these with all these proceedings
the Republicans just have to have the
nuts to do something no it's it they
have the Republicans have balls of steel
which you know don't you understand
Kevin McCarthy has iron-clad testicles
people just don't understand he's not on
your side he is standing in front of
your face with a with a with a
grin smiling saying I'm here for you
while holding his hand behind his back
with his fingers crossed it takes balls
to look into the eyes of an American
citizen say I'm working for you but
knowing deep down inside you are lying
desperately trying to protect the the
uniparty establishment
yeah I look I I think also there's a
shift to when you start to see
um
what's going on in Hawaii right now and
the negligence of
Joe Biden and how they're responding to
you know the the effort to get them
supplies and money and like the local
government like I think that things that
Joe Biden is also dropping the ball on
is another push for people to be like
yeah I I'm just done with this guy like
Trump comes out with you know a
statement yesterday and does what the
three minute video or something about
Hawaii and people are like why didn't
Biden do this and this guy's not even
the president right now I don't know
what the federal response has been
exactly I would like to know um but I
feel like this is like a call up the
Navy strategy where you like mobilize
the Navy to protect and preserve that
area of the United States because not
only are people suffering 1300 people
still haven't been found 70 people have
been declared dead or something like
that the entire city of Lahaina has been
burned to the ground for the most part
not only that it's a National Defense
vulnerability to have a broken area of
your country that's not functioning it's
an easy target so they need to protect
it
while your president is on the beach
he's on vacation I I it's almost like
they're doing everything in their power
and one of the things we talked about a
few years ago is that they want Civil
War so they can abolish the Constitution
because you that's the only way you do
it yeah and there's also a push to I
know that people are pretty aware that
the the definitions of words have been
shifting uh considerably the past you
know five ten years people who have
noticed that things don't mean what they
used to mean or whatever and there's
there's a tactic in that too if you can
shift the meanings of the words that are
in the Constitution and the Law changes
then you can change the meaning of the
law if you can get General woman yeah
exactly you know exactly and if the so
the the thing that was pointed out I
heard James Lindsay talking about this
but it was the uh land dedications that
you hear if you can convince people that
they're on Stolen land then they don't
own that property because it's
illegitimately obtained and that means
you're not protected you're none of your
rights are protected if you're on stolen
property that means you have no right to
that property anymore more and that and
so now I'm not saying that that's
exactly what's going on that that's the
intent behind it but that could be a
very happy side effect that people could
use to go after people's property you
guys remember John Teeter
we talked about it I don't know briefly
tell me it was back in the 2000s this uh
guy claiming to be from the future yes
oh yeah yeah there's a website and it
was you know Silly nonsense but one of
the things he said was that the country
would fracture into four different
regions controlled by four different
powers Europe would control a faction
China would control the faction Mexico
and Canada would split a faction it
seems to be silly nonsense but I bring
it up because
I don't think A revolution is possible
in the United States because the country
is much too big
that's just it uh you look at what's
going on with with the Biden doj
ignoring Lahaina with him uh with his
son in the corruption
with the doj going after Donald Trump
you're not going to get every state in
this country just to be like well that's
legitimate
average 2024
here's my concern
there's not going to be a definitive
winner this is I it could be like 18 I
think 1876 was the year where they were
like who do we count
and it'll be akin to this why let me ask
you guys why should I assume the 2024
election will be handled better than
2020. I think it would be worse any
reason I would encourage you to never
assume anything in that regard I
feel like the fact that there's not all
of the issues with covid might be a
reason well they're trying to do that
again though well
no no no no no no we'll see Donald Trump
makes a bunch of claims there's ballot
fraud et cetera et cetera why would I
assume the Trump supporters
would say less
I can't just no the the assumption is
clear there's no way of ramp as if you
said earlier Phil the likelihood is that
in 2024
you are going to have
insane disputes over who are the
official electors because Trump
supporters feeling slighted from 2020
are going to be out in force with I'm
talking about lawyers but documents
filed pre during after and then you're
gonna have legal challenges to to a
certified slate of electors there's
going to be 300 legal challenges in the
courts that aren't going to be resolved
in time and they're going to go how do
we count uh something that's currently
in legal dispute the judges would have
to just throw all of the lawsuits off
the docket which they can't just do my
assumption is 2024 will be bedlam I I
don't see Democrats and Republicans just
being like well you know let me know
what you think with the ballots and then
we'll see who the president is you're
going to have Mark Elias you're going to
have the nclu you're going to have
various factions on left and right
lodging lawsuit after lawsuit and
various jurisdictions before during and
after the election and then what's gonna
happen is various different news sources
that are at odds with each other will
report various different things and
you'll have people in some areas being
like I'm I'm hearing the Democrats one
but the Republicans have electors too
they're they're being the state
legislature certified the Republicans
but the media said the Democrats won
what's going on
no now look don't get me wrong I mean
maybe nothing happens I don't know well
you said earlier that you thought it
would be impossible for a revolution to
occur in the United States and I guess
hold on what I'm saying challenging
because of the size if DC was taken over
by an occupying force and a military
coup Texas doesn't go along with that
that's what I'm saying there's no point
where the entire country just says
Revolution now we're under the under the
rule of Communism when I say Revolution
I'm not always talking about a change in
government
um and format like a government like
from a democracy or from a republic to a
communist state I'm not talking about
necessarily like that it's a revolution
is like a change it means to turn
forward so like a change of of the mind
I know this is like a maoist tactic
we're going to change the minds of the
people and but I do think that can be
done for good as well and it can happen
quickly with the internet I I I have
such a problem with that kind of like
changing Minds because that's that's
main that's trying to manufacture
consent or trying to get everybody on
the same page the the the
the ability that humans have to
influence people is only either coercion
or it's just through argumentation
convincing someone or forcing them but
what about when you perform like you I
saw you singing in front of like 10 000
people or something like that yeah but
there's no gear yeah that's I mean you
can you can entertain people
entertaining people and convincing
people to to believe in in your
philosophy is totally different and and
and the idea that you could get someone
just on a stage to use Charisma to
convince people that's a bad thing too
like I mean because like Hitler was
super charismatic but he was also
genocidal Maniac you know so you can't
just say oh this person makes me feel
good you know like I was saying earlier
today like I but like
My Philosophy is is fundamentally an
Enlightenment philosophy because I
believe that we can we can interact with
reality we can see reality and we can
test things and we can reason proper
results and if we just go by feeling and
just by saying oh this guy really moves
me then then you get you end up with
Barack Obama everybody that voted for
Barack Obama for voted for Hope and
change they were voting with their heart
they were voting I believe in Barack
Obama I believe in people I Believe In
Hope and change because I am hopeful and
we can change things for the better
nobody agreed on what change was nobody
did but everybody felt real good about
it we need to have people so we were
coerced well and we were I mean it was I
don't know some people could say we're
like oh worse but it was like he's cool
he's a cool talker he's a good talker he
was cool he smoked cigarettes outside
the White House yeah I mean this guy is
awesome I could party with him I'm
totally want change I'm gonna vote for
him yes I mean that that is true the
votes for Barack Obama were very much
votes for his Charisma and stuff like
that and it and you know there were a
lot of things that changed from when he
was running to when he was in office and
stuff so you know I mean that that is
true but you still like we need to have
people that we need to be able to reason
not just get wrapped up and we feel this
way and we want to have this kind of
emotional reaction and try to connect
with people and convince them and get
everybody fired up I mean you you do
want people that are motivated that
believe that agree with you but you want
people that have reasoned their way to
their decisions not responded
emotionally you know do you think I I
think and I should say that if someone
could stand up on stage fully
charismatic get everyone's Hearts
aligned and then provide them a
blueprint of strategy technically of how
to solve the system and like put it out
of their hands they've they've
galvanized the populace to focus on an
idea that's outside of the person
that that could spark a a mental a
Consciousness right it's not just the
brain it's it's like a whole full body
you know people start working out they
start eating healthier they start having
kids these are culture I think
everybody's tired I think Americans are
tired they're tired of being lied to by
both sides they're tired of being
constantly gaslighted they're tired of
being promised things they're tired of
being locked up in their houses and lied
to coerced into doing things that they
don't want I think they're tired and
there's no way to go back to like how
can we get everybody on the same page
Unity we need you're never gonna get
that anymore because of the fatigue it's
just they're just disgusted there's a
war weariness I know I've sensed it for
a decade just the pain the pain
conscious there's the dietary weariness
that comes from overeating or eating
crappy food that knocks your body out
it's hard to wake up in the morning that
fog too much carbs all that crap there's
that fasting is a holy tenet I mean we
could I mean we can go on and on about
that but I mean
Joe Biden people are tired by Joe Biden
too let's uh let's jump into the next
story I want to start by showing you
this image I hope you all enjoy this uh
this picture uh we'll have to uh we'll
have to open image in a new tab and then
we'll have to shrink it so you can
actually see it wow this is uh there you
go it's very tiny on the screen because
uh you can't
actually scroll around or whatever and
but uh there you go it's uh it's Donald
Trump and it says revenge on it breaking
Trump to a point special counsel to
investigate Biden family corruption if
re-elected this is the reason people
want to vote for Donald Trump you want
revenge
I'll vote Trump
I'd like Revenge what do you guys think
I would like justice and if that means
forgiveness and compassion along with it
Mercy apparently what does that depends
on if it's Greek or Latin right yeah I
go with the Greeks on these that yeah
let me tell you a story Ian
Donald Trump said that he would uh
criminally indict Hillary Clinton that
he would go after she'd be in jail and
then what was it two days after he got
elected he's like no no we're not going
to do that it's okay
Donald Trump should have gone after all
of these people with criminal charges
because they're corrupt evil individuals
and he didn't
because he said we're going to forgive
we're gonna be like you Ian we're gonna
forgive everybody and now they're
arresting us lawyers I wish he'd said
that he never really talked about
forgiveness he still talked crap
he didn't he didn't he didn't prosecute
he didn't direct his doj to rescue
nobody didn't like make good he just
told Hillary talk crap about him through
her I mean they all do it and then he he
didn't go after her yeah yeah he should
have because he said you should probably
be in jail and he she wasn't and she
also denied the election too yeah so on
an extreme degree yeah she what was it
she uh was it her campaign or the
dancing that funded the seal dossier it
was her campaign her campaign spreading
the lie that Donald Trump was a Russian
spy yeah Stacy Abrams how come she's not
in jail right I love exactly Brian Camp
is like for the past three years no one
has brought any evidence of voter fraud
I'm Like You mean past five years
because like you're excluding Stacy
Abrams what I actually said was yeah but
you stole the election from Stacy Abrams
you Russian Nazi
well do you really I mean you're allowed
to question elections in the United
States
he's getting prosecuted for doing just I
mean that might be one of the things but
it's the it's the job no it's not
literally it Georgia is not going after
him over January 6th they're not going
after his lawyers for January 6th but
George is why this whole charade began
is no no Georgia is going after none of
the charges related to January 6 and
Georgia Georgia has no jurisdiction
there they're charging Trump and his
lawyers for reaching out to State
Legislature uh one of one of the acts is
that they they reached at lawyers
reached out to the legislature and said
you guys should vote on this and choose
who you think should actually win based
on the discrepancies they said that
solicitation of a violation of oath of
office
not January 6th they're saying because
Donald Trump had lawyers go and make the
legal argument that they should take the
Constitutional path of upholding their
their absolute legislative power to
determine who gets the electors they
said so that's a violation Stacey Abrams
do that did Hillary have lawyers go talk
to electors I don't know
um so the Democrats had alternate
electors and faithless electors you're
also just now you're just arguing to
degrees not whether or not I'm arguing
that you're allowed to question
elections the United States again we're
the point is that's why Trump is not
allowed to because Trump is being
prosecuted and Stacey Abrams has done
this and Hillary Clinton has already
done this in a way it's the way Trump
questions
there are ways that can get you thrown
in jail of questions and Jenna Ellis one
of the indicted co-conspirators was only
charged on counts one and two which is I
think violating the oath of public
office and Rico they're literally saying
because she worked for Trump she's
guilty of conspiracy that's it
that's it now other people were charged
with like solicitation of the violation
of office specific things but they're
going after her quite literally just
because she worked for Donald Trump as a
lawyer
so no
you don't get to call a lawyer and now
you the it looks like the federal
government's gonna do the same thing
they're going to go after Rudy Giuliani
and Sydney Powell and a bunch of these
people if you if you guys go out and
tell everyone you can't question
elections in the United States anymore
you turned us into a totalitarian state
we did don't do it exactly what you
gotta keep kind of Faith say it I mean
we did no I'm saying if you go out and
start telling people you can't do this
anymore you you become a hand of the
state you don't want to become that guy
that's black pilled and tells everyone
it's over you can question elections the
United States
to do that oh go ahead no good good yeah
no what you're saying is is like we
can't run around tell people that you
can't question the elections right right
you can do that but well no okay of
course you could question the election
and then if you take any actions and
furtherance of your questions you'll be
criminally charged sure it depends on
how but possible like you could
literally just be the lawyer for Donald
Trump and they'll charge you with
conspiracy yeah but I think my theory or
my hypothesis if he hadn't told people
to go to the Capitol on Jan six none of
this would be happening right now and
peacefully protest
many other groups and organizations did
that worse
like I'm not saying it was right but I'm
also saying there's other organizations
and groups that did that also
at the Capitol like they burnt down a
church or they tried to burn or they
tried to burn down a church they set
fire where's the RICO charges that was
organized and planned they were all let
off of all charges we still have guys
that are still in jail from January 6
that that were at but just to say the
hot dog cart across the street I mean
come on there's got to be a point where
everybody on both sides is like all
right this is nuts right or no I think
so no I hope so there is not I mean I
that's why I'm into pardons I think of
it is if you don't care if you really
don't find some kind of uh like
spiritual fulfillment and finding your
enemies like forgiven if you don't get
that then think of it as a hostage
negotiation and you want those Jan six
prisoners out so you pardon them and
then you want Hunter Biden pardoned as
the hostage yeah think of it as a
prisoner exchange that's why you issue
Mass Pardons and maybe Society will
freak out maybe it won't maybe it has to
come from the top maybe it has to come
from the people first I don't know but
it can happen I kind of think of it more
like there's a guy running around
setting fires and Ian is like if you
please promise not to do it again we
won't put you in jail
it's like well I don't know about that
yeah it's like saying I'm not gonna put
you in jail for all those fires you
started if you do it again you're done
but I'm we're moving forward let's not
anyone light any more of those that
that's kind of the mentality
e
with the with the hope that they won't
and then what happens when they do
um well that's a loaded question if if
they do uh then you have to put them in
prison that you can't just keep yeah
yeah we can't keep playing the game
got it I don't know
it's wild to me that's all
well what what what's what's the next
step I mean we've got a couple months
away a couple we've got maybe I don't
know
seven months until we start going to the
primaries I think we got to record a
million to one because we need to become
a cultural center
that's a song
the song I read that Ian really likes
it's the best song It's Your Best song
that I have so far and it's just the
beginning so full disclosure I just
started following your music oh love it
thank you I agree it's great I don't
believe it's that important I believe
building culture is important because
laws are only enforced on cultural
grounds confidence is everything yeah if
people didn't have confidence in the
dollar nobody would take the dollar
which is why the US gives dollars to all
to countries all over the world for
garbage nonsense and that's why I say
that um
voting Republican is good because you
need actions within the government to to
alter policy and things like that but
for the most part what's going to change
this is building culture
yeah rich men north of Richmond it there
the corporate press is attacking it as a
far right wing
industry plant fake blah blah blah he's
the most genuine guy just a video of a
guy singing like I don't even like
that's the best thing for it though but
who cares if it's an industry like maybe
this guy got signed a long time ago and
they said we're gonna put up a music
video and ask people to promote it I'm
like okay it's a good song yeah it's a
nice day the the left the people that
are attacking it
are the best thing for its credibility
oh yeah because the people that are
attacking it are doing exactly what he
says they're doing it's the it's the
champagne social the idea of the
champagne socialist the rich Urban
people and those are the people that
while they talk a good game about the
Working Man when a working man you know
or an ostensibly not wealthy not
Cosmopolitan person is sitting there
singing a song about the struggles that
they're noticing in their lives all they
do is dump all over him call him all
kinds of names and it really he really
the lyrics really do tap into things
that are on a lot of people's minds but
the people on the left I mean they feel
like it's attacking them and they're the
ones that are making it about them
because it doesn't specify aside
laughter aside yeah obviously there's a
whole lot of you know insecure security
when it comes to the uh the remark about
Epstein Island and or the the line about
Epstein Island and stuff
um but it's not particularly right
leaning it in policy it's but it is
culturally right and that's why cultural
leftists really hate it and it you know
you can I enjoy reading the people that
hate on it because it's you know well
because it's like the people that like
you say something about but you're not
you didn't mention them by name but
they're guilty so they're like are you
talking about me yeah they feel quite
good so it's yeah totally about you
so
I I'm a big fan of I thought the song
was very simple if you haven't heard it
yet North Richmond north of Richmond um
it's first course first course pretty
basic but the guy's performance is out
of control we need we need that we need
like we need heart shattering sound to
to shake people out of this morose
yeah I mean like I said it speaks to
the the mistrust
of the average well of the establishment
by the average person you know and and I
think that that the fact that it
resonated so with so many people and and
went viral so fast and so viral so fast
I think that that's something that
really has worried The Establishment and
you have Rolling Stone crapping on
approaching all the crap on everybody
well I mean but they didn't always a
protest song That's supposed to be
something that Rolling Stone would get
behind you know it's protesting against
the government and and like you know in
the 60s that would have been or the 70s
that's that would have been right up a
Rolling Stones alley they'd have been
right there cheering them on but they
weren't because they're The
Establishment right they're the
propaganda arm let's jump to this
unrelated story but interesting
nonetheless Minnesota Town's entire
police force resigns leaving Chief with
zero prospects good to Hugh Minnesota a
small town in the Southeastern part of
the State lost its entire police force
after the chief and another members of
the force handed in their resignations
I think we're a little bit blindsided by
it but we're resilient we're going to
move forward
this has been three weeks now we have
zero applicants zero prospects I've
called every PD around for the youngest
guys out there getting in the game
nobody's getting in the game if you want
to keep the PD and this is something we
want to keep going with something needs
to change dramatically and drastically
and it's got to happen now one good Hugh
city council member praised the police
force for maintaining Law and Order in
the town of Goodhue I can probably speak
for everyone I say they provided
excellent Safety and Security to our
community Etc et cetera blah blah blah
and uh nobody wants to be a cop
so when I talk about what comes next
confidence people believing in federal
government
yeah at least in this small town and
it's not the only place we're seeing
things like this this is just the most
extreme example the entire police force
resigning we've seen similar things
before of Mass resignations from various
police departments what happens to a
town when they have no cops
well we can already see what's happening
to LA and New York when the law says you
can't arrest these people when people
aren't allowed to defend themselves or
their property but what happens when
there's no cops
it's not what people think people assume
if there's no police officers then
you're going to have rampant crime
actually I think in small towns it'll be
the inverse you know why
because if there's no cops to arrest a
criminal at all the criminals already
aren't getting arrested that means
there's no one to arrest the person for
defending themselves
which means in small towns with zero
police people will start arming up and
then if someone comes in to rob their
store they get shot then this person
says there's no government I don't abide
by any of that I don't know what they're
talking about they abandoned us a long
time ago and this leads to social
breakdown and and Decay but maybe It
ultimately leads to more Community
Building because if there's no cops
people have to go talk to their
neighbors to figure out how they're
protecting each protecting each other
yeah I think becoming a cop through
necessity kind of is more noble than
doing it for a paycheck doing it because
you we truly need protection and then
calling the greatest among us to protect
is like that's a calling you know it's
important to note the population of this
uh City it is a city is only
1176. did you see how many cops resigned
was that like five it was probably five
yeah you know into the entire police
force is like five but I mean if you
know they still resigned what did they
resign for uh it doesn't I don't it
doesn't I don't think it says
so how do you feel about the law that's
being passed in Chicago or Illinois
where illegal immigrants can actually
become police officers now I just first
I've heard of it
well illegal yeah illegal immigration
low paying competition from larger
cities is was a big component so they're
getting jobs in other cities they're
getting paid more going to bigger cities
I mean that makes sense once this law
you mentioned in Chicago do you know
what the name of it is or anything in
Illinois it's being passed here in uh
shortly I think it's November
um if you were an illegal immigrant
you can
also be a police officer oh yes that's
right that's JB pritzker's new law okay
non-citizen law enforcement yeah
so should we fill Minnesota's town with
five illegal immigrants not all at once
if you can help it maybe introduce one
at a time and let them get socialized
and you should I think that people
should like you know be like in the
United States legally before they start
working for the United States what could
you go to like that's a good idea yeah I
mean could you go to any country in the
world and just become a police officer
tomorrow confident you that's a no it
could be a way to earn something so why
do we allow it no I don't know about
that either I don't think we should I I
honestly like like I'm super for like
point being is are we this desperate
right our police officers like leaving
the police force and and record numbers
if I understand correctly I mean I don't
have any you know data on it but like
that's what it seems like this is a
house bill 3751 in case people want to
look into it
um I I wonder about like letting people
earn ways for people to earn citizenship
um and if joining military a lot of like
they do that you you can do that by
joining the military and I think the
military is one thing but but just
coming to the United States and and
joining a civilian police force I think
is different yeah I've never heard up to
this point that that would function but
maybe it would be a good way too you can
buy citizenship
yeah yeah one thing that people do is
they'll uh you don't need to be an
American citizen to start a company in
the United States so they'll start a
company then they'll hire themselves and
use that as justification for yeah
there's also economic uh uh visas where
it's like if you have a certain amount
of money invested then you get to stay
in the country I have no problem with
people coming to the us that are that
are you know looking to
improve their situation and and start a
business or whatever it's like that's
that's that's what I mean that was it's
one of the wonderful things about the
United States is is we've always been
open to people that want to come and
want to be you know want to be free and
and take advantage of the fact that we
are a mostly free country you know it
the problem is when it's like oh you
know we're just gonna have people that
we're going to allow people to come in
and then as soon as you get here we're
going to get you onto some kind of
government uh you know subsidies or
government program or something that's
the bad thing before American citizens
yeah Lilly no just at all like if you're
here illegally you shouldn't be getting
better
but they are getting it before American
citizens yeah true but they shouldn't be
getting it at all not about I I don't
think that there's a before U.S citizens
kind of thing in that I don't think if
you're here legally you shouldn't be
getting 100 like unemployment and stuff
like that yeah you shouldn't be getting
that those things you don't eat I
understand there are people like oh if
someone's here they're paying taxes Etc
you know I get it that is true but to me
it's just not convincing it's like if
you're here illegally you shouldn't get
service free services from the
government Beyond this the immediate
stuff that everyone else gets like if
you show up at a hospital and you need
an emergency you need emergency care
that shouldn't mean that you get sent to
the police and get sent you know get
sent out of the country if you if you
you know if you're if you need the
police to help to help you the police
shouldn't automatically wrap you up like
the regular B cops but you know there's
a whole lot of DHS out there and they do
a whole lot of messing with your average
people when they could be looking for
people that that have you know skipped
their uh their their hearings for
whatever they call it when they come to
the to the country or whatever so you
know I wonder what percentage of illegal
immigrants are actually like superheroes
that
but like people that are like sub super
human intelligent like very very top of
the level they would have came here
legally yeah that's that's they they
have a brain to come here legally
they're probably well lost in my opinion
successful in their own country and then
they buy a private jet to fly in and get
a special class Visa one of the bad
things about people that come to the
United States the people like that that
come to the United States if they're
successful people that are coming to the
U.S from under you know uh uh people
from countries that have lower economic
you know output and stuff like that the
people that are successful they're
needed in those countries so if you're
like a doctor in you know somewhere in
in Africa and there and you're a good
doctor in the major city in in you know
whatever African country you're talking
about and you leave to come to the U.S
that's better for you but there's a lot
of people in Africa that we're relying
on you being the good doctor after in
town taking care of them so there's it's
a double-edged sword when you're like oh
we're gonna do we're gonna accept we
want to accept good people that can
contribute to our society if you're
taking them from the third world country
which they have every reason to want to
get out of there I get it but if you're
taken from third world countries those
people are the ones that are the most
necessary to help build those countries
that they're coming from so that's you
know it's just a a struggle idea that
you that people need to think about when
it comes to immigration brain drain
causing brain drain on other countries
yep yeah it's definitely uh you could
argue that it's International defense to
have the best brains damn be the
consequences but uh I get what you're
saying we're a holistic world and we
should support other nations as well
yeah I mean my grandparents came here
the legal way I mean they weren't
doctors or anything but they came to
this country for a better life and in
back in the 19 whatever was 70s and they
were like what do I got to do to be a
U.S citizen what is the what what I got
to do just tell me what I gotta do and
they did it that's it they were normal
people
they did it they became citizens they
raised their families they came here you
know so I'm not saying there's no good
people in that Bunch that are coming
here illegally but I'm also not saying a
majority of them are probably the rock
stars that you're talking about I think
that makes sense because it's super
super phenomenal humans will probably
figure out how to get here legally of
course because they're not going to want
to go across the Rio Grande but when
they have all these skills they're going
to want to be like hey how do I how do I
come here so I can because I got all
these skills and we'll be like
absolutely like come on over if you're
trying to smuggle kids across the border
you're probably not the person that
should be here and if you're one of
those kids it basically it doesn't even
matter if you're like a 16 year old but
you're like a super genius and you're
getting smuggled across the border like
that's not I don't know yeah it's law
it's a tangent yeah
it's unfortunate the cop thing in New
York I feel like
man
dude they've already got non-citizen
voting in place in parts of California
and New York
that's it global global citizen One
World Government whatever you want you
think there's value to letting people
earn citizenship through serving in like
civil like police and fire department no
fire department maybe not law
enforcement law enforcement you you I
think you've got to be a citizen
fire department though I can respect
that and say okay you know we'll put you
on the fire department or something like
that but the problem is there are people
here who want to be firefighters and get
paid to do it yeah there's there's huge
weightless it's very difficult in big
cities to get that job it's a good job
it's I'm I guess in situations like what
we got in Minnesota where five they
can't hire a police force like would it
be reasonable to hire no yeah to have a
non-citizen enforce the law that's
that's that's dramatic erosion of of
your country your social standards your
law
yeah a guy putting out fire is totally
different right they're saving people I
mean yeah just putting fires on you you
don't need to speak English or no
American Doctrine to put out a fire you
do you probably should know probably you
should at least know the same language
with the with like the lieutenant or
captain on scene who's instructing
people on what to do to put the fight
yeah you got to speak English
no you don't need to know American
Doctrine to put out a fire it's a
universal language get the hose buckets
yeah I mean there's yeah five people we
just need five firefighters for this
town we got this I think there you go we
can cover this police force just this
table
I think we see a lot of this stuff uh
cops resigning because of what happens I
mean it's Minnesota I wouldn't be
surprised if a component of this people
are resigning because of what happened
to TaoTao
oh the cop who was simply present while
George Floyd was killed got he got what
five years so who wants to be a cop
nobody
especially when you're you know I have
family members that are were in our cops
in Chicago and
during the riots during the BLM stuff
they they got bricks thrown at their
foreheads and they were the same cops
that were playing basketball with the
kids in the inner community so they're
like why am I doing this anymore like I
I am a good cop I don't need bricks
thrown at my head and then no support
from our chief
I'm out
bye you guys listening anybody want to
be a cop put a two in the chat if you
want to be a cop
and then put a nine if you don't want to
be a guy yeah put a nine if you're not
interested there's got to be an
alternative number and he's like two
there's gonna be people one I guess
people gotta wannabe cops to be a cop
like you've got to have faith in the
system be like I love this city so much
that I want to make it safe that's one
of them that's the real like caustic and
and bad thing about the a cab sentiment
it's not just that that like you know
you have issues with the existing cops
if your whole Community has the attitude
that all cops are bastards who wants to
help who wants to be a cop and the
places that have the people that are
screaming a cab the most are places that
need the cops the worst
mm-hmm you know I mean nobody wants to
be a cop now do you think that the uh do
you think that being a police officer in
a community that has a cab written on
all and written graffiti on all the
walls around and and and you can't get
the the community to talk to you and
help you
find any you know solve crimes or
whatever do you think that that any cops
wanna I love I love that story from
Elliot page about some guy screaming
and chasing Paige into a store in West
Hollywood or whatever because now I'm
pretty sure West Hollywood has the
community safety person advisors or
whatever instead of cops good it's like
yeah people in like vests instead of
police officers or something like that
so it's you can make this news story
where you say I was accosted by a
deranged man okay can we point out that
it's the left that advocated for the
removal of these police so now you're
even less safe have a nice day where did
a cab come from do you know cops was it
like inserted like it's a gen Z thing
it's just like no it's not just I don't
know I've never heard of it it's been
around for a long long time there's um
yeah it's a it's a leftist one three one
two really I didn't know that one three
one two is acab oh and that's where
12 comes from yeah oh okay I I mean I've
never been anti-cop so I didn't know
yeah 12 is a reference to one three one
two so they're just saying f are
bastards but whatever okay got it and
thank you for teaching me that okay so
that's like I mean my mind these days
goes to like Communist Revolution tactic
the Chinese have implanted this in my in
my social media now people think all
cops are bastards but they're not it's
like but but maybe it's more just like a
self-hatred thing like things because I
was so critical of the United States in
2007 because I was watching the war in
Iraq in the war in Afghanistan and and
hated it so much I was like good the US
dollar we don't want to be hegemonic
anymore stop like stop being the World
Police and now I'm like what is that now
I'm like realizing what does that really
mean like if we just stripped ourselves
of being the authority on Earth that
there be another one would step forward
so like maybe destroying our own home
just because it's not the best it might
actually be the least worst
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com click join
us become a member because we're gonna
have a members only uncensored show
coming up for you in about a half an
hour it will be on the front page of
timcast.com you don't want to miss it if
you're a member for at least six months
or the 25 per month level you can submit
questions and even call into the show to
talk to us and our guest but now let's
read what you all have to say
I'm not your guy friend says we've now
crossed the Rubicon into Banana Republic
territory as of last night no it's
Communist Revolution territory not
Banana Republic territory
checking in on our poll from earlier we
have at least nine people down to be
cops so I'm encouraged wow that's great
fox tashikata says I'm not your friend
pal that was too fast cheers timcast
crew keep up the good work really do
appreciate it
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I finally
got the American flag beanie now I must
turn it upside down to represent the
current political distress status of our
country
and in these three years the political
landscape has only deteriorated how of
us
who of us how of us have recently woke
up just to realize the country has been
taken over by an evil that will not that
will stop at nothing to gain power
yep
Devin says when will we get a guest
appearance from the King need to hear
how he feels about his return to the
throne it's long overdue Hail to the
King and rooster emoji
yeah we're not going to bring him on to
uh IRL anytime soon he's the he's now in
charge of chicken City once again he has
returned and uh it's unfortunate we
buried Roberto Jr today oh he is now
buried just outside of chicken City in a
in a chicken grave wow I went and gave
my paid my respects today is all that
yeah yeah Roberto Jr he was uh and his
sister died they they were the first
eggs we incubated from the chickens well
they were
weak Bunch but it's weird that she died
right after he died
that's really weird yeah
yep
I mean it actually makes a lot of sense
their brother and sister they were
incubated at the same time in the same
way and they were from the the chickens
had just started their adulthood and
it's their first babies and
a weak Bunch they're connected
sure or that
let's read some more Super chats
Paul taskelo says as a general rule of
thumb I evaluate the veracity of a legal
document based on attention to detail on
page 20 of the indictment Act 2 is
listed twice they had 2.5 years to do
this and couldn't proofread it not
guilty wow amazing
purple says beep boop bop thank you for
that
Devin says Tim what's your last draw
what would we need to get get to in the
Civil War for you to leave the country
or to pick up arms and fight
I don't know I think I only I I'd
probably only be defending myself I
think self-defense
there's no answer to that leave the
country hmm we're really close to the
point where throughout history people
flood their country out of fear of
political persecution
I mean look January 6 outright is an
example of it and it's it's fascinating
how uh desperate conservatives are to
deny reality not all of them some of
them
the doj is arresting people who walked
peacefully into a building with the
doors opened by police with no warnings
no barricades no signs
yes I know and I say it every time there
were people riding on one side of the
building they should be criminally
charged even Trump said that
but they're raiding the homes of people
because they walked onto the capitol
grounds having no idea what was going on
waving Little American flags and then
they left
Plato uh fled after Socrates was
executed The Plato and a bunch of
Socrates other followers were like let's
get the hell out of here because this is
not good yep I think people forget too
that like it's the same thing is going
on in Canada or happened in Canada with
with their truckers right and they had
the Convoy I think they have political
prisoners as well they do so are they
really oh yeah pretty sure they shut
down their bank accounts yeah yeah they
have nothing but anyway I I think it's
possible for people to flee the country
sure but then Plato came back 20 years
later and founded the academy right
outside of Athens so you know nothing's
temporary a lot of people who flee
return when things calm back down but I
hope people just understand that they
indicted Trump's lawyers
I would be surprised to hear
that no one fled the country
I don't know anybody who did go back to
Kaiser yeah but that's for different
reasons economic yeah Max and Max and
Stacy went El Salvador to help they
actually they didn't flee they went
there to make it better there they enjoy
that well they went there to help
Bitcoin yeah and to to embrace Bitcoin
and expand upon it and El Salvador has
been doing amazing I guess people that
are really fleeing persecution don't
announce it publicly no and they don't
talk about it they're just gone they
just leave but
you know you read these stories out of
world war out of Weimar Germany
and you read these stories about people
for you know Jewish people who live in
the United States and they're like oh my
grandparents left before the World War
II and it's like but how did they know
and it's like because they could see
everything that was happening and they
knew well what what the Nazis were
advocating for because so they got out
and a lot of people didn't and stayed
there and I write I'm like I read these
stories of people who are denying they
didn't believe it could get that bad
yeah they just indicted Trump's lawyers
I know
his lawyers
and people are just like oh and it's
it's no it's whatever whatever dude read
please read about any Civil War read
about any Revolution this is the
breaking point is this the kind of thing
if it's a conspiracy charge doesn't that
mean that either they're all guilty or
none of them are guilty I would assume
so no not necessarily
because one person might argue that they
were never actually privating the
conversations and that they were wrongly
charged you know what I mean yeah this
all seems to stem from the fact that the
belief that Trump knew that what he was
doing was it was wrong if they will go
after your lawyers
you have no legal Protections in this
country you have no rights they are just
going to lock you up correct
a lot of j-sexers could not get lawyers
because the government is going after
people yeah if if the government
if the government prosecutes lawyers for
defending people or for giving counsel
that's violating one of the you know the
the right to counsel the right to a fair
trial you can't have a fair trial if the
government is intimidating lawyers from
working with John Adams represented the
British After the Revolution
deserves due process so due process is
done but that that's literally true that
something like what I said earlier the
point is to strike fear into the
population lawyers are going to be
afraid to defend people that have the
the wrong political opinions this is so
this is the the behavior of the
government is intended to frighten
people and to spread the message that if
you if you have the wrong opinions and
you are vocal about them the government
is going to come down on you and the
only right
sorry but the only right opinion is what
we're saying is is the Biden opinion
right that's the only one you're allowed
to have and it's not so much the Biden
opinion but it's probably the last
politically curve well the blood Biden
Biden is 80. Biden doesn't I don't
believe he knows anything I believe that
he's being handled so it's not like he's
the one that's making the calls so other
people are making the opinions and he's
saying them and he's the mouthpiece but
Joe Biden like Joe Biden isn't wiping
his own butt never mind actually you
know he's sitting there like I am wiping
my own butt Phil I really don't believe
that he's wiping all right let's read
some more we got infinite Soul dad he
says can I get a shout out for my 20th
anniversary my wife and I love the show
also if you're going to talk nutrition
you need to find a legit legit sources I
highly recommend Dr Lane Norton biolin
oh yeah shout out for your 20th
anniversary happy to hear it hope all is
going well
armored Jester says I never called you
crazy Tim I I too am cursed with being
ahead of the Curve
I I could be wrong I'm just saying all
you have to do is say here's the
scenario in which Democrats calm down
that ultimately leads to the point where
Biden and Trump hug high five and wave
an American flag together
I'm being somewhat silly but just
explain to me a scenario in which
following his indictments Trump
supporters say guys let's stop fighting
DMT yeah I really doubt it psilocybin
MDMA there Bo Burnham uh bernison says
next Casper commercial idea we recreate
the scene from psycho where Ian's in the
shower and gets pecked to death violin
Screech and all we were just talking
about that well no but but Ian has been
converted by the coffee so the next
commercial needs to be someone else and
the question people are asking is what
would happen if he didn't drink the
coffee so I think what we do is we have
somebody
similarly waking up to the scream
running but they go into the kitchen and
they say get the coffee ready but
there's no one there and they go crap
then they run in and start trying to
Fumble with the coffee and they can't
get it and then Roberto shows up and
they're like I'm brewing and I'm brewing
it no no no
and then it shows them backing into the
corner and then you see just the
silhouette of the rooster pecking and
then you see like a silhouette of liquid
spraying in the air
yeah and the car you can see the coffee
mug in the shadow
and then you hear the the weird demonic
crowing and it'll just be like drink
Castro coffee
yeah I mean I like it then the next idea
is Ian walks into the room with his with
his eyes glowing and he says hello
friends would you like a glass of
delicious cast brew coffee and
everyone's like oh yeah sure I guess and
then one by one they all drink it and
then turn into zombies just like him and
go this is good coffee
mine's a little cold I'll zap it with my
red eyes
and then you can have someone be like
wow does Casper give you super powers
and then he drinks it then yes it does
tastes good doesn't give you superpowers
let's grab some more Super chats
T-Rex patchop says has Luke gritkowski
explained why he complained so much but
doesn't vote one thing I always say is
you can't complain if you don't vote Tim
how many mealworms do you need live or
freeze-dried I have no idea I know I'm
not the chicken tender
I no longer take care of the chickens I
used to go out there periodically and I
would I would feed the chickens and
they'd all run around doing chicken
stuff
oh how can we answer that about Luke why
does he uh complain all the time and not
not all the time why does he complaining
not vote apparently he came out uh
complaining about DeSantis recently
despite praising him quite a bit over
and over and over again you in the chat
Luke why why do you do it because he
advocates for personal responsibility it
starts with him and his community is
that what he said no that's just what I
believe about him huh I don't know if
he's listening right now
we will grab some more Super chats is it
worse to not vote
in your opinion um I only vote if I
believe in the candidate truly I will
not vote an election if I don't find any
of the candidates sufficient okay that's
fair but I will tell people to vote for
a candidate I believe in and hopefully
that generates more than one vote I feel
like that could be more effective than
one vote
all right Melissa wood says I'm more
concerned now that they are hedging
their bets on Trump being elected and
they are warning anyone that may accept
a position with his presidency they will
Target and Trump's left uh left
toothless
interesting
AC DC says Trump has been charged with
more indictments than Al Capone and John
Gotti together whoa unreal yeah but they
couldn't get component anything they got
him on tax evasion wasn't that wasn't
that it tax division
Anthony Brownlee says I live in Georgia
and I am sick of these corrupt
politicians thinking they know what's
best for me and my family I'm ready to
make a stand quit my job and run for
office but I'm calling for help to get
started not money just information where
to start
uh Google I suppose I'm not entirely
sure maybe you could meet with local
officials go to a local congressman's
office and ask them and and see what
they could do for you see what they can
tell you
Trent lamolino says I had only plans to
vote for Dave Smith but with him not
seemingly wanted wanted wanting to and
everything going on with Trump I'll vote
for 45 Savage
yeah I'd have liked to vote for Dave
Smith but I want Trump to win I'm not
sure Dave is is running I don't know
what's going on with it
there was like rumors of him doing it
but I don't know what's going on there's
a lot of rumors going around the
libertarian party about who may or may
not run I've heard a bunch if I
understand Dave is not going to run is
that publicly known well I don't if if I
understand I don't think there's been
any kind of like confirmation that he's
not but the you know he hasn't announced
and everyone kind of is like running
around looking around for someone for
the Libertarians the rumors I've heard
is that the mises caucus guys are trying
to find someone
and their choices are awful
one of them one of the choice is that
I've heard is he's a friend of mine he's
a nice guy I don't know if he's I don't
even I've never seen him hanging out
with Libertarians I've never seen him
post about libertarian stuff I don't
know if he knows he should do it I don't
know if he knows who mises is Ian
uh Ian's not very libertarian like all
the time but not no libertarian agrees
any libertarian is libertarian so it
works perfectly that's as you were
talking I was like how can a Libertarian
run the country because the whole
purpose is that you've decided
libertarian would be cool to go in there
and decentralize the government though
it's a funny thing about libertarianism
versus communism Communists believe that
every communist country wasn't real
communism and Libertarians think each
other individual libertarian aren't are
not real Libertarians as soon as you
want the state to do anything you're not
a Libertarian yeah
Eeyore says I'm curious if y'all heard
of the gun YouTuber Brandon Herrera
running for the 23rd District of Texas
yes I think you'd be a great guest for
the show love the show keeping the great
work we have we have absolutely it
Brandon who's the homie
promotional email says don't know if
this made the rounds yet Marion County
Kansas police conducted a raid and
seizure of local news agency reporters
in their equipment happened a couple
days ago and I believe the woman who
owned it while they they were getting
raided she died of like a stress heart
attack or something like that I heard
about that well I didn't know that it
was a woman I thought it was a man but I
heard it died of a heart attack it's
like an old person who owned it and then
while the police were I guess it's in
like an illegal Ray they just dropped
dead yep jeez welcome to America right
let's see chafed BM good name says it is
time for prosecutors in red states to
start indicting Fanny Willis Jack Smith
judge chutcon Alvin Bragg etc for
election interference then issue arrest
warrants for them and hold them without
bond anything goes now yes but there's
no GOP they're not going to do anything
they're not going to do anything so
that's the thing
says Ian they want Power it will never
be enough for them make no mistake they
want any opposition to them to be
illegal yeah who's they
maybe maybe someone listening wants to
do this there's that song by GEM from I
think like the 2000s called they and
just listen to the song and it's
hilarious by today's con today standards
because of what it implies based on the
you know Ace like the ACLU and the splc
and the ADL maybe not ACLU but the 80 on
the splc
and like what are some of the lyrics
someone's like um
I can't remember the song but look up
the lyrics and I was thinking it would
be funny to make a video where you have
the song they any any song that refers
to they as a protest song and then after
every key line from the song it's Kanye
going who is they though
you also have I was into Muse
um I've got the songs called but in the
song they're like they will stop
degrading us they will like yeah people
know the song and I'm like we were
skating and the song comes on
they will stop uh ignoring us or
whatever I don't know what the lyrics
are and I was and I just went who is
they though and I'm like there's a lot
of songs that refers to they as people
in control and power and I think we just
need the compilation of every song
that's talking about they you know or
them and then just having Kanye jump in
actually you could probably do we could
probably do a cover like you could
probably do like a full song where you
make an amalgam of all these different
songs and every time that line is sung
you get actually in sequence with the
song who is they though oh I'm like
pitch correct it yeah that'd be great
that's doable that'd be funny
where are we at
clunky Jew says j6 was in support of
Pence to reject the counterfeit electors
except Pence was a coward and backed out
so we were left with Biden it's not it's
not necessarily about even rejecting
counterfeit is about the the principal
argument was that in some instances
Governors changed the election rules
without the approval of the state
legislature or courts did and the
argument was these electors should go
before the state legislation there
should be a session where they vote to
certify this if they want and if they
don't then they make a decision
and Mike Pence was terrified that the
Deep state would come for him
as they're coming for everyone else so
there you go
where are we at
let's grab this one
Tyrion says did Ian just honestly say
Trump has poor people skills he's loved
by his employees he's negotiated with
his enemies and helped bring peace they
attack him because he has those skills
and is uncontrollable
um yeah I didn't think I didn't say
people skills it was uh but it was
similar to Socrates like he angers
people you know some people are well
liked by everyone around them and some
people are more divisive so he he pisses
the people that he's pissed off is
coming back to haunt him I think
um
but like he called Rosie O'Donnell a fat
pig in public that's crazy
I think more than once it's disgusting a
fat pig
Triton 54 says the 117th Congress is in
its infancy had to step over the dead
body of a veteran to confirm the
electoral vote for the presidency tell
me again we are not in a civil war
the argument against the Civil War as a
term is that there's not discernible
factions shooting each other in the
streets
the argument I suppose is
if it escalates to that point they will
refer to this period as a civil war
right right so it's like
yeah it depends it depends it'll be like
one more German like Weimar Germany with
all the different factions fighting the
streets
yeah yeah
I guess I guess it could be if it goes
the Spanish Civil War route you get a
right-wing military coup and if it goes
it could go the Nazi route or it could
go the Bolshevik route yeah pick your
poison yeah they're all awful fighting
in the streets before lunchtime yeah
bittoren says how does Trump ever get a
fair trial by a jury of his peers how
many billionaire Real Estate Mogul
former presidents are there
yeah there was uh people are looking up
the names of the grand jurors and
apparently a bunch of them are Die Hard
leftists oh nice I just saw the video of
the 30 year old girl that was like the
foreman on that one trial she's like oh
yeah looking like this and yeah I was
eating a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
popsicle when we invited
I don't remember what is that girl's
name
that was crazy yeah it was crazy Patriot
American says Tim in my opinion the next
civil war is going to be a mix of Ira
guerrilla warfare tactics from the 20th
century with modern 21st century
resistance tactics like hacking using
technology to inflict damage physically
it's going to be all yes drones no no I
think I think there's going to be like
poisonings I think they're like they're
and and look what happened in Russia
with that that influencer who got who
was given the statue that exploded I
think I think in modern fifth
generational Civil War you see things
like that
there will be hackings there will be
industrial control system hacking and
things like that uh Power grids shutting
down
but I think
the escalation path for this in terms of
street level violence
I don't know if we get to that point
where the street level violence is
inherently worse is substantially worse
than where it was a few years ago
because
those extremists are now in government
or the government has become extreme to
where they're just arresting their
enemies so you have antifa fighting with
proud boys in the street yeah that's
phase one the next level is now the FBI
is antifa and they're literally just
going and arresting anyone who opposes
them
so in that case you won't see it's a
revolution you don't see us you don't
see civil conflict and then if they win
history records evil people were
arrested you know the fascists were
stopped before they could rise to power
do you think that American republicanism
can exist on the global stage yes
I think it's the perfect way for the
world to operate
people have their own sovereign states
they can live the way they want to live
and then there are uh courts and
councils so that we can adjudicate
problems like I have I have I have uh no
problem with International treaties and
cooperation on solving uh
International problems
I don't like the idea of a totalitarian
communist One World Government I like
the idea that instead of going to war we
file a lawsuit with an agreed upon third
party and then one country here's the
you know we don't fight over it in fact
I would prefer if there was a
territorial dispute we have a soccer
match over it like anything is better
than blowing each other up yeah you know
but who knows kcb says I unbelievably
agree with Brian krasenstein
interactions IRL with political
opponents are usually cordial IMO any
future widespread violence would be
aimed at the government enforcers who
impose penalties on 80 centers wrong
just tell that to Aaron Danielson who
was shot twice in the chest for no
reason go to any any political rally
where whenever conservatives say they're
gonna have a rally the left shows up and
mercilessly beats people years ago I
watched them throw an explosive at an
old lady who then fell on the ground and
it was it was a a M80 M80 I say
explosive people think it's bigger M80
dangerous can kill you especially an old
lady blow your hand off yeah and she
falls down and gets knocked down by this
and I'm like this is nuts like they're
throwing mortar shells at people at each
other
it's it's the craziest thing that winter
comes around and people forget what
happened a couple years ago it's like
wild man memory how memory is so yeah
you had you had Jazz you had them unload
hundreds of rifle rounds into a white
SUV killing two teenagers and they're
like but interactions are cordial dude I
want you to imagine the Civil War do you
think that the dude who like worked at
the Shoe Shop walked outside and went oh
I'm gonna go punch my next door neighbor
because he's got different political
views than me that's just not what
happens
grants and granted in Syria it's
eventually what does happen in
full-scale uh societal collapse I think
what the super chatter was was intending
to to mean is that when you have an act
like a diplomatic conversation with
someone you can get through to them
regardless of political affiliation when
it's one-on-one not necessarily in
crowds I mean not not at rallies and
stuff that's that's a hard place to
strike up a conversation but like here
for instance on a show or something you
a lot of times can have really that's
why the United States has stood the test
of time to this point is because we've
been able to talk about wildly different
political views I don't know if I I
completely
agree
I think
it could be revolutionary in the sense
that the left has taken control of law
enforcement institutions
and they're going to use them to stop
the right from getting control back
but why are those people not terrorists
can you answer that for me which people
the the when you just explain that
they're throwing m80s into groups of
people right yeah but they're not
because their allies are in law
enforcement there you go right and so
Donald Trump was unwilling to use law
enforcement to stop these people and
they are willing to use law enforcement
to stop Trump
they're they're they're uh there were
official like uh documents that that
declared
antifa terrorist organization I'm
confident that that actually happened on
a federal level
um so Federal on a federal level and
team is considered I'm pretty sure they
have because yeah I'm pretty sure
they're still going after right wing
well I mean people um they'll go after
they'll go after them both
they they don't and anyone who
challenges their Authority I mean I'm
personally emotionally I'm more of a
right-leaning kind of guy
um but like it you know they I don't
like the government at all and the
government will go after let people that
don't don't like the government they
have no problem there's a bill uh house
resolution
272-272 calling for the designation
designation of antifa as a domestic
terrorist organization that's from
2021-22 uh of October of 2021 I don't
know if it's if it's passed
it was introduced in March of 21
introduced and just sitting there the
the FBI and well the FBI has has
sufficient latitude to go after anyone
that they want to consider a terrorist
and the definitions are loose enough
nowadays that they can pretty much just
slap the the uh the moniker on anyone
they want and you know the the media
will repeat the story and then people
will automatically believe oh well that
guy's a terrorist because that's what
the government said the Xbox gamer says
Tim how about that Tim cast clip
featured at the end of a new Trump 24 ad
saw it in a Benny Johnson video earlier
today I think the Don wants to chat I
have no idea to which you are referring
has anybody know what he's talking about
no I saw that Benny Johnson tweet what
tweet uh four minute clip of Donald
Trump talking but there was no ads that
was on Twitter on X I don't know if
that's what he's referring to maybe not
I don't know no idea how to find
whatever it is you're talking about
either way a Benny Johnson YouTube video
Twitter video it was a Twitter video
all right let's uh
puppy on a train says I live in GA there
was a question here about mail-in
ballots with the duplicate signatures
one of Trump's requests was a signature
verification to remove double ballots
Governor Kemp did a standard recount
that's right
that's right they did remove some double
ballots Atlanta Journal Constitution
confirmed that but yep
Adam Helm says ask Phil if he will sing
the Oliver Anthony song sometime that
would be awesome
the Oliver oh the uh Richmond North
Richmond I'd have to learn it
make a metal version metal cover it's
screaming yeah
[Laughter]
a better future says Tim it's Muse
Uprising thank you for what you do for
the culture War Sir that's right
uprising
yep they who is they though still trying
to find out Jesus yeah I want to put
that together just get a whole bunch of
so there's there's gem they and there's
Muse Uprising what other songs are there
where they talk about they
in Richmond north of Richmond he
outright just says Richmond north of
Richmond are doing this thing he's
telling you who they is yeah who who is
they though people in DC politicians and
political Elites
where are we at Joshua mosque says with
everything going on we found out the
government and the FBI suppressed the
hunter Biden story and a whole lot more
Joe Biden admits they had a fraud
campaign going do you still think the
election was not rigged rigged when did
Joe Biden admit they had a fraud
campaign going
what did they say that what are they
talking about
uh I think they were a friend of the
clip when when Joe Biden said we put the
mistake yeah that he had like the
biggest uh voter fraud operation going
since like whatever great moment great
moment and the full context was he was
saying it was we were stopping it yeah
yeah so all right everybody if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends it really does help by
taking that URL posting it everywhere
and head over to timcast.com click
become a click join us to become a
member we're gonna have that members
only uncensored show up on the front
page of timcast.com in just a few
minutes and we will take your calls and
your questions you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast conservative Aunt
do you want to shout anything out uh no
thanks for having me I had a good time
with you guys today right on and uh you
guys follow me conservative van
everywhere
all over
I am uh Phil that remains A Philip
remains on X Philip remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify
on uh YouTube on Pandora what's the
other one Spotify YouTube mines Apple
music there you go uh thanks Phil thanks
Anthony good to meet you man and I'm Ian
Crossland follow me on social media and
I actually on X I did a uh my first
space today at four o'clock P.M with
Zach Voorhees we talked about artificial
intelligence God and and uh quite kind
of deep it was pretty awesome I'm gonna
be doing a lot more of those I don't
know what what platform to do it on
YouTube you can do video that's pretty
cool mine's just introduced streaming
and of course spaces spaces has no video
and I know the face is nice but uh yeah
let me know they're bringing uh
Periscope back if I understand questions
I think you can do it now like elon's
done it a couple times so I'm not sure
if you can do it right now or not but
very cool it's coming apparently follow
me there follow me on all those websites
Eddie and crosson I'll see you later
and I am surge.com looking forward to
the after show uh yeah I have ekis now
so follow me on at keys.com
all right everybody we will see you all
at timcast.com in just a few minutes
thanks for hanging out